hello and welcome i'm james murphy did
you know that not all exceptions in
python derive from the built-in
exception class that's right not all
exceptions are capital exceptions
this is almost correct though let's see
what happens if we try to raise
something that's not an exception
here i try raising a string
and i get an error message that says all
exceptions must derive from base
exception not exception
okay so all exceptions have to be base
exceptions but what's the difference
between a base exception and an
exception
well here's the official documentation a
base exception is just the base class
for all built-in exceptions
on the other hand a plain old exception
is for all built-in non-system exiting
exceptions and all user-defined
exceptions
clearly the python documentation is
telling me that for my own exceptions i
should be inheriting from exception not
base exception
so what are the built-in system exiting
exceptions that it's talking about here
we can find out a little bit lower in
the documentation by looking at the
exception class hierarchy
from this list we can see that python
has only three built-in exceptions that
are base exceptions but not exceptions
looking at the first two now we know
what the authors of the documentation
meant when they said non-system exiting
exceptions system exit and keyboard
interrupt generally cause your python
program to stop
generator exit on the other hand doesn't
cause your program to stop and i'm not
quite sure why it's a base exception and
not just an exception
my intuition tells me that it should go
wherever stop iteration goes but i'm
sure there were good reasons for doing
this
but let's move on and stick with the
main intent of separating base exception
from exception let's investigate why
it's useful to separate exiting
exceptions from non-exiting ones
consider the following example suppose
somewhere deep down in our code
something fails and we want to exit the
program so we call sys.exit
here we've wrapped the whole thing in a
try except where we're catching all
capital exceptions
as you can see none of the print
statements execute
that's because sys.exit raised a system
exit exception which is a base exception
not a capital exception
what we're assuming here and what is
normally the case when you're
programming is that for exceptions you
want to catch logical errors or failures
of functions to succeed
handling these kind of business logic
exceptions is generally what you mean to
do when you use a try except this is a
very different type of situation than
what's going on if somewhere in the code
someone tries to exit the program
generally speaking if someone's trying
to exit the program you really shouldn't
be stopping them
now of course you can catch a system
exit if you want to do something
specific in that situation but normally
when you say catch all the exceptions
this is not what you have in mind if you
want to catch all the exceptions then
you just use a bear accept or an accept
base exception keep in mind though that
in my opinion catching all exceptions is
almost always a bad idea in my opinion
you should always prefer to use the most
specific kind of exception that you can
think of
if you expect a type error or a value
error then use them
don't depend on except base exception or
accept exception to just catch
everything i know it's really tempting
to just use a bear except because it's
less to type using a bear accept or an
accept exception is way too broad and it
will often lead to catching and possibly
silently handling errors that you
weren't expecting like here i passed the
wrong kind of argument to system.exit
but during the execution of the program
i have no way of knowing that
moving on let's see what can go wrong if
you do try to catch all exceptions
instead of just non-system exiting ones
so i'm going ahead and running this
program it's doing work it's doing work
it's doing work
and i decide that it's taking too long i
want to kill this program so i go ahead
and hit ctrl c and try to kill
it no matter how many times i hit
control c the exception handler is not
allowing me to exit the program if i
want to kill the program i have to kill
the terminal itself or kill the python
process at the operating system level
however if i just catch capital
exceptions
then i can kill it with ctrl c and i get
a keyboard interrupt
this is a common mistake that people
make especially when accepting user
input from the terminal
as a side note if you really just want
to kill python and not ask it to shut
down nicely you can do that using the os
dot underscore exit function
you can see that when we run this code
nothing is printed out because python is
killed it doesn't raise an exception
like sys.exit does
os exit just kills the program
most of the time you only really want to
do this after you forked a new process
and then want to kill it
but it's good to know just in case you
have to
finally what's the deal with generator
exit generator exit is not a system
exiting exception but it is a base
exception not a capital exception a
generator exit is raised inside a
generator when you call the generator's
close function before the generator is
finished here we create a generator and
call its next method once it just
yielded 0 and now it's paused while it's
paused we call its close method and we
see that gen exit is printed out we see
gen exit printed because the generator
exit was caught by this accept handler
notice however that we re-raised the
exception but we still don't see a trace
back that's because much like a stop
iteration used in for loops a generator
exit is not really an error a generator
raising generator exit is just python's
way of telling you that the generator is
done python silently handles a generator
exit just like it silently handles a
stop iteration for a for loop again
honestly i'm not sure why this is a base
exception and not an exception in any
case though that's all of the built-in
base exceptions in python that aren't
themselves capital exceptions you can
technically make your own base
exceptions by inheriting directly from
base exception but the documentation
tells you that you shouldn't do this
well that's all i've got on exceptions
thanks for watching i hope you learned a
little bit if you liked the video please
consider subscribing share it with your
friends and as always slap that like
button an odd number of times see you
next time